be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we continue our discussions on
Marvel's omega-level mutant we pick up
now with David Haller also known as
legion now for those of you who are new
to my channel the classification of
Omega level is provided to mutants whose
power exists on such a scale that they
present a threat to the planetary
systems of the world for example Iceman
possesses the power to manipulate the
cold but because cold is the absence of
heat and heat is generated by the rapid
movement of molecules Iceman is
effectively controlling molecular
movement by speeding matter up or
slowing it down as a result
Bobbe drink is a threat to any planet
whether it's capable of supporting life
or not likewise Omega level telepaths
like Emma Frost are considered to be
Omega level due to the fact that if she
chose to her skillset would allow her to
seize control of Earth's entire
population bidding them to her will and
even forcing humanity to launch its
nuclear weapons leading to the complete
and utter destruction of Earth however
while all of the various omega-level
mutant that we've discussed so far have
a singular power with no definitive
limit Legion is completely unique owing
to the fact that he can arbitrarily
grant himself powers of unlimited levels
and in turn subconsciously create or
consciously absorb personalities to go
in each of those powers as a result
while we only know of a few dozen it's
acknowledged by various individuals in
Marvel Comics that Legion has hundreds
if not thousands of personalities each
one possessing a different power and so
in order to make this easier to
understand
I want to experiment with this video and
take it in a completely different
direction for my previous videos by
using the same approach as the Iron Man
armors and then I'm going to run over
some of the different personalities of
Legion as well as the powers they have
and what they mean so beginning with
David holler himself having no control
over his actual powers the first
personality to manifest came in the form
of Gemayel Kumari debuting in New
Mutants number 26 Gemayel was formerly a
terrorist acting to kill various
israelis around the Middle East
kidnapping David hollars mother owing to
the fact that she was a member of the
israeli diplomatic service the
experience of being kidnapped
combined with witnessing the murder of
his mother's partner caused Legion to
destroy all of the terrorists present
and absorb the mind of Gemayel who
embodied legions powers of telepathy
because the limit Allegiance telepathy
does no
exist gmail is able to manipulate this
power to achieve a variety of effects
including the creation of telepathic
shields to protect the mind telepathic
cloaks to hide his presence telepathic
camouflage which can trick the mind of
others into believing Legion is someone
that is not absorb unlimited amounts of
information through mental transference
place information in the minds of others
walk through the dreams of others
control the minds of others create
amnesia see the future as well as a host
of other capabilities
moving on to Jack Wayne this personality
was the first to appear within the mind
of Legion that did not result in the
absorption of someone else instead this
personality was created organically as
an arrogant adventurer and debuted in
New Mutants number 27 following Xavier
realization that Legion was actually his
son Xavier had sidetracked his missions
with the New Mutants in an effort to
figure out exactly how legions powers
worked as well as why he had been
creating multiple personalities
possessing control over legions power of
telekinesis Jack Wayne was capable of
controlling living organic tissue
forcing the muscles of beings to cramp
up their skin to break or blood vessels
to burst in addition to this he
possessed the ability to emit
psychokinetic energy from his mind
manipulate all forms of energy in the
electromagnetic spectrum fly over any
distance create force fields heal
himself manipulate the forces of gravity
phase through solid matter alter the
molecular structure of matter create
holograms and constructs as well as
activate and negate the powers and Jesus
this guy's powerful I'm sorry guys I
just had to say that this is insane I
can't I got how to write or send this to
me and I can't believe that he can do
all I've verified it I can't believe he
can do all this stuff
if sorry for breaking character this is
crazy
picking up with Cindy this was another
personality created by Legion as a
rebellious teenage girl who debuted in
New Mutants number 27
during Xavier efforts to study the
powers of Legion possessing control over
legions pyrokinesis Cindy was able to
manipulate fire in a multitude of ways
including the incineration of objects or
beings with the exception of those
existing at the cosmic level in addition
to this Cindy was able to absorb and
breathe fire create projectiles made of
fire create fiery projections initiate
fire storms ranging from several feet to
over 50,000 miles and radius and for
spontaneous combustion
moving onto X this personality emerged
as a predator of sorts consuming a
multitude of other personalities within
the mind of Legion attending to figure
out what was happening Charles Xavier
and a mutant super genius named dr.
nemesis investigated the mind of Legion
after which the predator personality
worked reality and took the form of Mora
McTaggart the ex-girlfriend of Charles
Xavier
all the while having initiated at Online
called age of X which existed as if the
x-men had never been created while
things were set back to normal and the
personality was reabsorbed that being X
represents the most powerful personality
of Legion and that she's entirely
capable of warping reality on a cosmic
scale however something to point out
here is that X is not on the same level
as characters like Franklin Richards or
Madge M Jasper's or even Matthew Malloy
and that these individuals powers are
not limited to their own realities as a
result X in and of herself is simply a
mega level as opposed to beyond Omega
level
picking up with Susan and sunshine while
the age of X ended with the return of
reality
several of legions personalities
splintered into physical bodies one of
which manifested as a young girl while
she did have the power of telepathy
unlike Gemayel she did not have the
ability to manipulate all facets of
telepathy
instead Susan and sunshine was isolated
to controlling the emotions of others
creating happiness or conflict however
if Susan herself becomes unhappy her
power dissipates to the point of
becoming a normal human moving to
time-sink much like susan and sunshine
this personality emerged as a byproduct
of the age of X possessing the power of
chrono Kinesis time six powers are
pretty straightforward and that he has
the ability to mentally manipulate or
alter time allowing him to travel
through time speed or slow time down
control time around single individuals
groups or places as well as reverse or
enhance the aging process in addition to
this because both space and time aren't
in a weave time sync is able to
manipulate space but only insofar that
if he sends a person through time
they'll also travel through space
moving on to chain this personality also
emerged as a result of age of X and
possesses the power of self replication
however unlike multiple man who could
produce copies of himself from his own
body chain creates copies of himself by
touching others who in turn live and
function in accordance with ensuring the
survival of the original chain as well
as carrying out his orders regarding
bleeding image this character is also a
result of age of X and
the power of empathic pain transfer
meaning that much like a voodoo doll if
he inflicts pain on himself that pain is
felt in the same place by a targeted
victim with all the same side-effects of
real pain which includes broken limbs
sending that person into shock or even
death of picking up with endgame as a
byproduct of age of X this personality
manifests as an entity composed of
adaptable Armour much like Darwin who
can adapt to any situation to ensure its
survival in games Armour performs the
same purpose allowing it to adapt to any
situation that would result in this
destruction which includes becoming
intangible possessing super strength
developing plasma based energy attacks
as well as transmogrifying the armor
into another material that works against
an opponent's power finally and focusing
on delusion not with uncanny x-men vol 2
seeing the formation of cyclopses
extinction team composed of earth's most
powerful x-men and tasked with
eliminating threats that could lead to
the destruction of growth itself the
team sought out Legion leading to a
battle between the extinction team and
David himself during this conflict
delusion not manifested as a personality
capable of creating illusion so
intricate that Omega level telepaths
like Emma Frost were unable to tell the
difference between these illusions and
reality itself with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end and again this is only a handful of
the personalities that Legion has there
are so many more so if you guys are
interested in seeing more videos like
this make sure you drop a like post a
comment down below tell me what you
think and I will catch you guys later
please